tens of millions of americans tried to
put this pandemic behind them over
memorial day weekend
they hit the beaches they were at the
airports boardwalks
on the first holiday in more than a year
when most of us didn't have to wear a
mask didn't that feel good
and at a time when more than half of
american adults are fully vaccinated
right now we have the lowest number of
new covet infections in the us in more
than a year
so here's a question how do we keep it
that way
over the summer joining us now is dr
ashish jah he's dean of brown university
school of public health
good morning to you very good to see you
dr jar we're going to get to you right
away
good morning gail thanks for having me
on so this is the thing all the experts
are saying
do not rush to victory yet it's not time
we still have a ways to go but i think
that ship has sailed
if you look at what happened over the
airports you look at people that were
celebrating
i think people think it's over and you
are here to say what
i'm here to say if you are vaccinated
it's largely over
uh we're going to have a really good
summer uh especially for people who are
vaccinated two-thirds of adults now
uh almost two-thirds are have at least
one shot
i think that's terrific i remain worried
about people who are unvaccinated
because we have a lot of
very very contagious variants that are
spreading across the u.s
and so for people who are unvaccinated
it remains a risky summer
but for the rest of us it's going to be
a really good summer i know i'm now
walking around with this vaccination
feeling that i have some type of
superpower
do you feel that if you come in contact
with people that are unvaccinated
what are the chances that you will get
it because a lot of people as you see
are still not vaccinated what is your
concern
yeah so i think outdoors i'm not
concerned at all so i
if i'm outdoors and there are
unvaccinated people around me
it's i think you're basically fine i
think it's when you have
large indoor gatherings and let's say a
lot of unvaccinated people
there is now there is still a little bit
of a risk but
if you're fully vaccinated gail you're
really in good shape and there's very
very little risk
in almost any circumstance you know last
year last memorial day
weekend there was a big update uptick in
cases
what do you pre what is your prediction
this time
yeah you know gail i'm a little bit
worried about um the south and i'll tell
you why last year
right around this time we saw an uptick
in cases actually more than an uptick we
saw a big surge in cases
in the south because obviously starting
to get hot people are spending more time
indoors and this year the problem is
there's still a lot of people
unvaccinated in many of the southern
states
so that's what we've got to work on if
we can improve those vaccination numbers
i think things will be fine
but i am worried about an uptick in
cases in many of those states
what can you tell us about the timeline
for a booster shot
you know i think there's been a lot of
talk about boosters i don't see boosters
coming anytime soon i think
these vaccines are i don't i don't think
most of us will need a vac
booster in 2021 i mean maybe next year
but
uh i really am i'm skeptical that we're
going to need one anytime super soon
these vaccines
are really remarkable and i suspect
they're going to give us protection for
a good period of time
and if you've gotten your vaccine should
you still be getting covet-tested
asking for a friend you know yeah
no look if you don't have any symptoms
no obviously if you wake up with a fever
a cough sore throat any of this stuff
if you have symptoms you should
absolutely get tested uh because
breakthrough infections do happen but if
you're otherwise feeling fine and normal
asymptomatic testing for people who've
gotten the vaccine is really not
necessary
all right dr ashish we thank you for
your time
thank you